hello happy after the Wednesday Lobby
stream stream back back back to back
yeah I guess that's you you're going
back to back for sure yeah yeah we're
gonna play Star Wars Battlefront 2 early
access and open a [ __ ] ton of crates
Rob's favorite don't shake your head
yeah you're gonna enjoy this
I hope so no I I know so yeah and we'll
get into more that later we want to
cushion that you know I let it build let
it build right cuz I actually you know I
want to have some enjoyment first okay
so we're gonna play some campaign cool
all right so the first three story story
missions are available we're gonna do
the first very first mission just a
heads up and then after this we'll head
into multiplayer probably play a masher
to mash or two rather and then we'll
open up some crates yeah cuz that way we
can get a nice comparison just open the
open I don't know we'll see we'll see
what's what the people say no loot boxes
says cuz you always get the Star Wars
goin
well gameplay I like it
captain she's highly-trained deception
infiltration extraction she's Special
Forces I didn't versio inferno squad
commander versio you must be important
look at me so let's talk facts that's
what I'm here for
you have the activation code I've got
the ability to help you out just give me
the code you know we can really use
someone like you just help me it'll help
you it's that easy I'm gonna get what I
want eventually my best technicians are
slicing into your droid right now take
out my offer all I want is the code the
empire's time has come you don't have to
go down with it you're right the
Empire's time has come
[Music]
to memory which can't do anything if the
droid is deactivated until here's the
excess adios a little off the voicings
use a little quiet cool
some iTunes droid
your mass once you back out okay hey
boss we're hacking what droids do this
guy's chillin so that's really good Oh a
milestone
that's gonna give me some credits Eric
[Music]
also hey what's up guys to everyone and
you do too it's like that
possibly Twitter as well thank you guys
for tuning in we were playing Star Wars
Battlefront see the first mission in
early access and we will get some
multiplayer and everyone's hearts the
light loot crate's later most people are
actually
buying loot boxes brings you closer to
the dark side don't do it says Cozumel
I agree that's why I'm really scared and
opening them I guess I'll go in here
what the hell
okay that's a lot okay
stealth droid oh hell yeah you're gonna
do I want to shoot lightning out of my
hands or also the lie that might be
might be able to bring people back to
life
according to it's like they knew our you
know it's transferring energy oh I
thought I was past tune oh all right
mission failed let's do it again
yeah we don't need mad wrinkle cream
that got lightning hands we just don't
fight mace windu good you are the chosen
one
oh you're crazy I like it though well I
figured I could like wait in there but I
guess in between that area is no bueno
yes PC maxed doesn't look as good root
for those who are watching but it looks
really good here I got a little scanner
all these gadgets are rolling out she
sounds really dark like a livestream
schedule that they stick by so balloon
shock me that you know maybe that's why
they're playing
yeah because originally a lot well I
mean in my researcher looking into
details when this because again this is
origin access so you can play the game
for ten hours before getting shut off
and I originally thought it was for
tomorrow and then and then I went alive
and that's oh [ __ ]
and that's or for those of you don't
know ea origin access it's a
subscription you get for for ei origin
and you could play games much earlier I
think maybe a week early again only only
for ten hours generally and only for PC
and Xbox one I can't I don't think right
here yeah Kenna no not here I guess I
gotta shut this guy
yeah I wish I had more footage I mean I
played pretty well but like James Duggan
over at IGN I was more often not when I
played that first day at the multiplayer
then he was on my team or like I just
generally didn't really run into him
they were different servers going on I
did kill eg my good joint ok well they
don't know they'd know yeah I mean it
looks really good like the reflections
on the gear so here's that gonna do
first person I think no controller of
his third person nice that wasn't
necessary yeah I know
oh wait with why I guess ok
they want you to talk that nice troy'd
clutch that looks like the same room is
this the capital ship and return of jet
I think it is they have the briefing
before they convince the end or you've
seen the movies yeah again we're gonna
play the first mission and then we're
gonna get into the multiplayer stuff
here we go now now I got my first person
is this your preferred or do you like
third person why I like third person
more because I can see you around the
corners also I got a scope on this gun
and I can't aim down through a
interesting
I'm not an Ewok and chewbacca Oh double
Tina I can see these guys better when
all stealth today are you nice little
generous slide Oh too late they were too
slow I think I yell that last time you
didn't see nothing amen
yeah that's a that is a tough stance I'm
really enjoying this droid
he's just pushing Burmese it's weird the
audio of the voice is low I reckon I
could change it maybe that's enough I
love that noise
same as know I guess that is very much a
Rebel Alliance siren we've been huh
why do you guys want to open hoop boxers
end record because we want to see well
hey how bad it can be 1 & 2
I'm Chris of like what you end up
actually getting each other anything
good and also we can do the test of like
Rob can put on star cards to see if it's
like legit broken can we get a great a
lot of good ones yeah
I could have was all that Goldeneye
Goldeneye and halo and I also played a
lot of this I fight a lot of beta and I
played a lot of the I got the role right
where's my role at why when they give me
the world damage I can go that far down
I got the role the classic role
imperative and multi player play that
much Oh we'll see the role soon good
damn your bulb base gifts as I might
join ei start sided with this game it
looks a - doh it really does look good
can't deny it
it sounds great well in theory I mean
technically you could assuming you had a
PC or Xbox you could just buy early
access right and play for 10 hours you
could if you have the EA access yeah
spend five dollars for a month kill it
this is so classic Star Wars shoot shoot
the locks
showing that what's down here so there
are collectibles as you saw earlier for
those who were joining us I used the joy
to open up a like a crate funny enough
and it uh it was a milestone meaning
outside of this game there's a menu and
I can you know it's challenge my lessons
are challenges do this get a collectible
do that in multiplayer and campaign a
life good call
go my child Wow really fast and they'll
give me credits generally or crafting
parts for the multiplayer which then I
use for the loot crate's
to get star cards yeah it is she could
roll I just want to make sure you play
the game that you want so with this nice
little kind of rental system why not
Malik
he'll wants to know how does the game
play is it better than the first
absolutely game play is absolutely
better weapons were more diverse you
have like active reload and and and
cooldowns that are specific they they
have varying degrees of recoil a lot of
different types of weapons because I
think the last game they all kind of
felt see me among other things but
you're not really done and then there's
I mean yeah the flake the big thing for
me and I said it so many times is the
flying and the last game was atrocious
it was horrible
now it's like Criterion studios we just
studios Criterion reworked all the
flight controls and it feels awesome
it's like like battlefield comparison
which is where they really should have
just done from the beginning because
it's flying is a tricky situation where
that like not many people get a full
grasp of how like pitching and rolls
work in a plane so they like and I don't
blame it they oftentimes will like kind
of dumb it down make it really
simplistic where you're just on a
horizontal plane but then you can't do
barrel rolls and ever wants do a barrel
roll but here you get
both options you get to like make it
easy to fly so you have Auto roll
contact confirmed but yeah it's it's
great and it's the maps also have for
flying have like obstacles or not just
like open so all you're doing in a
dogfight is just circling around and
into circles just turning left and
hoping to get to get around someone now
there's like tons of things to like fly
into or fly under Camino is like really
cool looking flight underneath those
like kind of water structures and how
people get kind of I have people crash
into things it's fun it's really fun and
part of the dark side we knew we were
gonna do it we've done it with overwatch
and other ones it's for science like I'm
curious to know what happens again we
spend a hundred dollars not my money
we're lucky enough to have a company
that will let us test that was so sick
and we're gonna find out what a hundred
dollars will do to this game
because we're not tent we're not talking
about cosmetics we're talking about
gameplay like damaged boot above booths
longer heals quicker cooldown looks like
you're still second-in-command agent
Miko those jump calculations were
perfect
thank you ma'am the landing wasn't too
rough been through worse remember the
job s incursion still wants my dreams
contact the Admiral yes commander and
the message
the fleet's location is still safe today
the rebellion dies I don't know what
that one smaller the first in says we
boxes need to die ah damn right I think
oh oh really
I mean you are on the dark side I am on
I am on the dark side I just feel like
damn it yeah take it off all right one
after this okay
I'm nothing
oh so now where the battle is returned
to Jedi now
oh man member this new squad now
oh so this is second mission by the way
a recovery team Admiral but we're too
late to capture the saboteurs what's the
status of the dead star shield generator
worse-than-expected there's no way to
repair or reactivate eliminate the
rebels are returned to the Corvis the
Emperor's plan must not fail yes sir
agent hath would be agent Miko cover us
from here
[Music]
ooh damn that was nice vegetation this
game looks so good it is definitely a
spectacle I've seen some of the gameplay
you and Alessandro as well as Aaron
brought back and it looks good
so are we out of here or yeah I think we
should unless people really want to see
more of the campaign but I for one
wouldn't want to spoil that so much okay
let's get to more so back to my the
point I was gonna make about loot boxes
I don't necessarily think Luke boxes are
a bad thing now that's just me it's
personal opinion but it depends on how
they do it yeah right like I feel like
there are certain games that have done
it like fine and well and it's totally
up to you if you want to do it or not
and then there's other games that maybe
it's a little bit more exploiting a
little bit which we're kind of gonna
test here in a second so those
milestones are here in the career
section of your menu you go into here
and you're gonna open these guys up I
McClain and I get 500 credits for
finishing the prologue the cloner so at
least you're getting credits within the
single player right that then affects
your multiplayer and in your ability to
buy stuff that's right here top right
there yeah first currency there's
credits in the middle are crystals
actual money that you will wish submits
into the game and use crystals who also
open blue crates now on the right there
are crafting parts crafting parts you
use to also unlock and upgrade cards so
the change that they originally the best
cards in the game are out of will call
them legendary okay those are the best
cards in the game they previously said
that you can only get those through loot
crate's which people were really upset
about including myself so I said alright
now the only way to get them is by
upgrading them
so I can't do it now because I have to
be a certain level but I could craft
with crafting parts and get this card
opposed to getting it in a loot crate
and that 4d crafting cost is for the
first tier right and that's
exponentially and then it's 80 and then
I just in the beta it
last one was 480 crafting parts which is
a lot yeah because we're gonna see how
many you get in a box or crate right
yeah and we talked about the lobby and
I'll be honest I still find this whole
progression system very very confusing
so we'll hopefully learn as we go but
let's start opening these things so oh
boy
so uh just to show people their
pre-order right these are from the
pre-order which I got and if we go to
this menu whose yeah where you would buy
crystals so I did this earlier so we
don't have to see how long that took but
it did not take that long to be honest
and yeah if you have origin access you
can look at that Eric get a little
discount yeah a little discount $10 off
and that's this is roughly gonna be 60
maybe more loot crate's
so that's origin axis is the y-axis
right right $5 month okay see if you I
have you say five yeah that's not really
saving ten if you think about your right
whatever your that's fine
hi I'm sort of needs up this is again
origin access trial so the thing here is
that thank god dude
all of this look at that that is a
that's the best that's one of those cars
I believe all right I believe that was
just from you pre-ordering yeah and is
that that one's random this is I guess
this is an epic so I think this is the
best part for Yoda sure less stamina
when striking so I can just go ahead and
put that on spam your strikes now but
we're not gonna spend the time I don't
think okay putting all these things on
that's probably because put the good
ones we should just yeah sure we can do
it later okay so which one was this is
this kylo still all the pre-order crates
that I got no I know what I thought it
was like a kylo centric 100 wasn't gonna
yeah that's kylo including his silencer
Wow okay so you get all these if you
pre-ordered got it okay
don't hold it in turn up I want to hear
more of this loop that noise seriously
yeah I really want to hear it okay so
Eric what's really frustrating I mean
we'll get so actually I can't say
nothing right now because these are all
the pre-order crates we haven't gone to
the actual in the game so frozen ice
beer saying you can't get epics and loot
boxes they need to be crafted now well
we just got some but they were hero
specific and these were three orders so
I again I I'm not quite sure I don't
know if epic is the best card or not
okay but I believe they said at the end
of it right and there was we wouldn't
know if you could upgrade anyways
because you'd have to be like a certain
level to do that right what you said on
the lobby yeah you have to be a certain
level in order to craft and upgrade your
star cards okay I didn't see the box
this was this was this okay well you got
specialists 3000 credits that's pretty
that's a lot yeah that's a lot that's
like that's basically a loot crate and a
half all right what do we got here we
got another epic that's purple right so
on the screen
ooh a thermal detonator isn't that man
too good two weapons oh so so that's a
mod I believe in the middle mhm
so these are these are specific to are
those were those classes right there are
four classes they're everything you see
as far as like like an item for your
generic infantry they're all specific to
that class and that's the only time I
can use them later Xander court we are
gamblers are these all if someone in the
chat knows if like is purple like that's
the best or I don't know yeah so if chat
knows if you guys know if a purple like
the the last tier that we're seeing here
like what the heavy combat shield is
that's the best you can get in the game
because I I thought they said that the
epics were not gonna be in case the best
cards in the game well maybe just those
those pre-order ones whoa no I skipped
it
whatever good job Rob well no this is
where we really go - all right here we
go
$90 for science I know some people in
chat aren't necessarily happy about this
but not happy live vicariously through
us even if you're not happy about it
we're about to find out how this goes
all right and we're opening trooper
kites right out of the three crates that
you had you can open the trooper crates
is the highest all I'll mix around is
there hundred is there more of a reason
to do the trooper crates if you want to
love up your infantry but like
starfighter will be starfighters God and
then the last one I believe is just for
he's just for Heroes just reveal all
yeah I got 60 parts 60 purses good you
said like five well it goes up and down
and again you were seeing earlier it was
like sometimes two items sometimes four
so that's pretty frustrating if you keep
going baby
how is it not what what do I push a I
don't know you know definitely not buy
more why it's weird I don't know I
wasn't working in there going well okay
so you had to scroll over it yeah
anyways sorry I haven't gotten the
rhythm down of the getting 0:05 you got
five are you sure it's too tough no I'm
not sure okay so 45 parts that times
that's pretty good survivalist okay
we're learning about crazy right now
so far four or five we'll see if we get
less than that yeah five again all
Commons though it looks like okay
alright but it's a starting ground like
I I now I now have a card that I didn't
spend you know the forty crafting parts
right so I can like then we'll oh okay
got a green this time
oh you got duplicate for 400 credits
right so duplicates turn Internet
credits Nessus 25 saying that legendary
is the best star card and epic is second
best okay so there is one more tier that
I guess you could crash so that's what
you have to up you have to use crafting
parts in order to get to the legendary
load Oh film I know we don't have the
credits but we definitely got the
crystals so he was saying that we
couldn't open it because we didn't have
for that but we got so many crystals
crystals again are the other the actual
real world money like five boxes now and
you've gotten mostly grays and greens
see this I can't even use this is that I
have to unlock I have to unlock help
Palpatine that's two you owe me like an
emo and I would be you know I believe oh
we have to press wise what bro get bro
Dameron brother bro oh we got a blue
blue rare I think it's rare I don't know
if that's the right terminology we got
improved jet pack and more parts that's
pretty good tractor parts don't seem
that bad Oh at least out of these crates
maybe it's different
have we been I haven't been notice about
crafting parts I'm looking for cartoon
uh we've been getting four and five
cards I haven't seen less than four
cards and it seems like at the minimum
it's at least forty five crafting parts
to sixty so I haven't seen anything in
between that I've only seen 45 or 60
okay and also I'm I'm realizing that the
as you saw earlier when I was opening
like a daily crates or like somebody's
like milestone milestone crates I think
those are gonna be the cuz you're right
it's been four and five so sixteen so
you're getting crafting parts you got it
you got 450 you could you could craft
the next tier how much actually no sorry
you have to be a level alright 480 to go
from from well that's beta I don't like
the look I mean a lot of dupes though
and we haven't gotten less than four
cards from what I can tell it to you so
it's been four or five
and again I feel like I cut myself off
uh the the daily crates are yet - some
of them were two items gotcha
Bob Jones mainly opening trooper crates
just because that's gonna help the
infantry as Rob mentioned the infantry
as you play that by the most yeah you do
and I'm actually gonna I want to open up
a star fighter one now yeah so the
troopers cost them it cost the most I
think it's two hundred so we're a hero
crate they recall the other day with
that time so I'm as a line firefighter
crate is 120 now this will only affect
your star fighters obviously as the name
implies Oh a blue off the bat hmm
Darth Vader Darth Vader reinforced hull
how good okay so you got a victory pros
in there as part of that okay so you
still get Starfighter stuff but you can
get other stuff as well yeah I just know
I know I'm a victory pose meaning if I
get MVP crap in ports if I get an MVP
rank in the end that's the pose I get to
customize sure so if it's if it's a dark
vault Darth Maul victory pose that's if
I play Darth Maul and did very well
yeah we haven't gotten an epic yet a
skate outside of the pre-order stuff so
the best we've gone out of the crates
have been blues and greens so also from
what I've noticed at least with these
crates is like it seems like the top
amount of crafting parts you can get is
35 in these ones since these crates cost
less we have knock on a 45 no I haven't
gotten a 45 or 60 out of the Starfighter
the highest crafting parts we got was 60
oh there's a 50 so 50 is the highest
here and then I guess 45 60 for the
other one watching this is like watching
paint dry well I've got that it's not
that bad for me it is when he gets four
Commons oh yeah ah good walk lightning I
think you should go back to Clyde I know
it's up to you
do you like Starfighter more mode more
anyways I really do so I guess it's kind
of better if you're getting some star
fighter cards so like does tuned laser
is that is that a pretty good one to
have like that you can't see exactly
what it is I'm imagining that's like
fire rate maybe okay so what we need to
do later - as another good way to test
is that Rob will like equipped cards
right like better cards and then he'll
turn them off or put lesser ones on I
guess maybe yeah
hmm how's it feel stop sponsoring the
game we're not sponsoring the games
you're becoming part of the problem
I mean we're showing you what exactly
you can and can't get I suppose you
could you could argue that opening
crates is not what everyone wants to see
but it's a reality that is in the game
and I feel like you guys should be
equipped with that information I agree
with you like I actually we didn't know
it totally how this works right
I feel like sans some of the stuff that
came out earlier right they also changed
it post beta right like you we should
know everyone should know what this is
like okay fifty King a lot a what I
think I need you to do two later
what is spend all your credits so that
we can see just like how long it takes
to get enough credits to open a crate
like if you were just playing the game
right yeah I know you kind of mentioned
that a little bit on the lobby they had
a chat about battlefront too and Rob's
impressions from going to a multiplayer
review events but it'll be good to see
on the stream to like what it would be
like if you were just to play the game
yeah see so right in the card you put on
two said vehicle or class will boost
your rank meaning that's how you get
another saw that too right yeah we can
show that too so you need a good if you
want to like raise your rank quickly you
can you can get a really great star card
by chance flaming wings uh clearly we're
not being paid by EA to do this if you
listen to any of the conversation before
of Rob's opinions of loot crate's and
things like that really good you would
understand that he is not a fan of this
at all now clearly you know we are doing
this but
we need to know I feel like you guys
need to know if you guys are that upset
about it I guess I apologize but you
know yeah I think the only reason why
people here upset about the loot crate
opening here is because of all the
negative connotations that battlefront 2
has had nobody has ever said to us when
I do a overwatch livestream with Joey is
there ever in the chat like why are you
guys opening loot crate's like what like
are you being paid by Blizzard like that
never happens but for some reason today
with Battlefront 2 there's more negative
comments in our chat than there has been
previously it's touch it's touchy when
they're not cosmetic and I am right
there with everyone who this is taking
but I will say once we get into the game
that you Erin and Alessandro have had a
really good experience just playing the
game yeah then there's all these kind of
mechanics counting the loot crate's that
are kind of muddying that feeling up
we're like you know yeah it's it's a it
bums me out sometimes or it does blow me
out like this we still have a got an
epic right so if there's a purple yeah
right we have not also we're getting I
know it's she's a hero nevermind I'm
thinking we're getting single-player
stuff but that's not possible
we're almost done with the crates don't
worry guys it's like a couple more I
think I think we're about halfway yeah
and as Sanvi gaming is is bringing up
overwatch it's not a pay2win whereas
this is or this can be seen as
pay2win and i I understand like we're
gonna find out how pay to win it is in a
way right because we're gonna be able to
play with cards and without cards and
write and see what that's like you know
and how much that might affect your
multiplayer experience right han Solo
and Chewbacca
now put the Chewbacca mask back on
I don't think you can get a legendary
Bob Jones it's not it's not possible
have you guys just been opening Lucas
for the last 45 minutes at John Lucas I
know that is we played the first mission
and we've probably done about 15 minutes
of loot crate opening give or take
we're almost there surprisingly not as
fast as you think it would be I guess
maybe because we're kind of like looking
at some of the stuff a little bit but so
far yes we spent about $90 and that was
with the EA access discount if you
didn't have EA access to be a hundred
but I guess you wouldn't also be opening
these if you didn't have it right now
right now yeah from the chat Darth tress
on us yeah so far the Purple's or yeah
yeah so never Chris gave us the epics
the purple that's been the only ones
that we've actually gotten an epic card
out of we've all been probably 40 plus
crates now and we have not gotten
anything past blue which was pretty rare
it's called rare but another percent
sure and we're rare in general like I
think we only had two three so far I've
honestly already lost count
Tanner Hartman asking do you think these
do you guys think that the loot crate's
evens out what the fact that future DLC
will be free I'm not necessarily you
know I there's a lot there are plenty of
games that have done loot crate or some
form of loot crate's that continue to
give you more content but the loot
crate's that are you know that can be
bought are cosmetic
they're not like they're not affecting
gameplay so like destiny for example
they have engrams
which you could buy for you know emotes
and you know it's shaders and sparrows
and things like that but those don't
necessarily affect the gameplay maybe
the sparrow
like could a little bit but not really
right it doesn't influence most of the
core game mechanics there overwatch same
thing you're still getting events
you know events throughout the year and
different like updates and things like
that and it's all their skins are
cosmetic their voice lines etc like you
know like you can play the game and
slowly acquire those or if you wanted to
you could pay to look good is what I
like to say pay to look good and I think
fine I think it's a way of giving back
into something that you like you're only
at 5,000 some of the chat was saying can
you please open it here oh great all
right yeah I'm not gonna be I've done
the last five or four I think I'm not
gonna do any more cuz I don't care about
heroes well the interesting thing here
is like you're getting four to five
cards and I think you were saying
earlier so we might have to tell them
like this but like you're saying you
were only getting one to two cards
previously but it must have been through
like different so these are the we're
when I'm opening here are like the the
standard crates that you keep opening
okay but there are also crates that like
daily crates real challenge crates so
those those types are different sorry
not good we are on PC print Greaves oh
you gotta have the rhythm so that's a
that's a jet trooper which is something
I would have to that's a battle point
thing in game so I couldn't just always
have that there's another blue rare yeah
so we still definitely have not we you
got crap to the crafting parts though my
friend yeah but you also need crafting
parts for mods right so right right
so the crafting parts don't seem as bad
as beta for sure from from the from the
what I've seen so far yeah I remember
when we did beta it seemed like it was a
dime a dozen
right when you actually got the parts
now I feel like you're getting them like
almost every time now so yep playing
Star Wars Battlefront
we should really just start playing you
think people in the chatter game board I
don't I don't have any problem leaving
but I feel like we made the commitment
yeah that's fine flaming wings I just
want to tell you too though like I
understand the the complain about
destiny and it's one time you shaders
but I have so many shaders in that game
now just from playing the game that it
doesn't it doesn't bother me I know that
it upset a lot of people but like hey
you still earn bright engrams which
could potentially get you shaders you
get shaders from like all over the game
some of the best shader the best-looking
shader in my opinion is actually in the
raid so I don't know like that is a
minor gripe compared to what we're
looking at right now but of course I'm
biased because I like to ask me how I'm
wearing a destiny I was like hey man I
surprised robbed is now at Star Wars
shirt on to be honest it's a nice
button-down seriously business sometimes
like I start with [ __ ] underneath it for
a craft talk alright we're almost there
we're almost at the home stretch guys I
promise I promise you gameplay although
we we only have until 2:30 at least I
only have till 3:30 then I have a
meeting
the time is around 12:45 okay whoops so
the so the interesting thing actually m3
gas you say so are these guys still
trying to get cool stuff even though
there are level 1 and literally can't
open anything good the thing is if what
Rob said earlier during the lobbyists
chew he could potentially equip a card
right and and progress that type of
character to it to a point to a point to
a point and then I I do have to like
play more dammit that's fine
people want to get past the crates you
cannot get legendary cars new crates
Admiral Paulus you have to craft them
now destiny to has no endgame the rate
is the endgame I don't know why I'm
going back and forth of this guy I guess
I'm trying to defend any but we have we
haven't even got an epic yet that's true
we have not we've only gotten rares out
of the crates
well sorry added the out of these crates
we've gotten epics out of the pre-orders
and they were like very specific to a
hero or to a class which I guess anyone
that pre-ordered would get correct that
is correct
Ned Flanders asking $90 nothing decent
no I think there's been some teasing
cars but I don't think like it's really
I don't know if there's a that's yeah no
nothing like which is which is I don't
know to some degrees makes me you're
you're kind of I'm not not as angry as
angry yeah but yeah what we will see is
we'll see how far we can get with a
clean slate right yeah by putting these
cards on cuz again you put the better
the card the higher your rink can get
yeah
TK a 470 and yeah TK 8472 asking how
many uh crates and no epics like I would
say we're in the like 40 range at this
point we have not gotten an epic sans
the preorder stuff I know that we got
something from that but that looked like
it told you you were gonna get that yeah
there were these have we haven't gotten
anything past rare and it it seems
pretty rare to get a rare so you could
almost argue there's really no point to
paying to buy crates right like I don't
know well we'll see once we try gameplay
how much I'm an advantage it is but at
least on the surface it doesn't seem
like us buying these crates are gonna
necessarily give us a huge advantage
over someone else yeah at least it seems
that way I don't I don't know about the
interest interesting though too is that
look at all the like I've been getting
credits as well out of this so like I
still have it's only enough for five
though yeah I guess you're right sorry
I'm slowing down no you're good you're
just not used to you're almost done yeah
we're almost there so close
come on so close the visible man 99 yes
boredom because I have no idea what
they're doing we're opening crates I
granted it was a lot maybe I should have
just told her off to only do the $36
version which was like Tony packs and we
were probably have been done by now
there's no in-between there was only in
between 36 and there was for $40 versus
100 like that's it oh that's okay all
right cool
are you gonna agree you're gonna do no
equip um what do you think I think you
should play one okay then equip and then
see what that difference is all right
we're done thank you guys for hanging
with us
I'm ready Steven call Brooke I think he
could have turned up the difficulty in
terms of campaign I think yeah yeah I I
agree it did look really easy or it was
really easy I agree with that we are
going to play a match of galactic
assault with nothing we are a day one
whatever he ends up picking I don't know
why she did you play somebody no I have
another cool I have not played you know
what's funny we just took up like 30
minutes of your 10 hours open he quits
[ __ ] you're right there's 10 hours of
display of early access I just plan it
let's get you
Dallas smogula early access has started
on Xbox and PC right [ __ ] in there and
that correct yes that's correct their
skills you want us to craft cards we
can't even you can't even craft hire
that wall I guess we could technically
craft rarest affix we just can't or
maybe with the Catholic sob you know hi
yeah thank you guys and I apologize I I
apologize and that I had I known it was
going to take that long
no man I was playing with the patroller
last ps4 pro okay well it is begin flank
my [ __ ]
what's switch shoulder and play if not
I'll take the mass back off some of
these maps you start really far away
actually it's too hot i'm taking a mask
off that's fine also the whole point of
the mask was only to wear when we got to
Mookie action which we may never ever
get sayonara asking at GameSpot is third
person cam available on console - yeah
yeah absolutely
well that's a hot room people throwing
grenades on the doors Oh
oh nice work as a headshot or a wall did
you guys have questions rob has played a
good amount of multiplayer at the
multiplayer review event but he went to
see earlier this week I just kind of set
him up to hopefully not fail don't want
to complicate his personages
all so he can play on controller versus
mouse keyboard so I'll give him that
that he's gonna get used to
Oh Lord what a grenade yeah so the
assault has got kind like a shotgun or
at least this first the default loadout
as a shotgun and then he has like a like
a dart sensor that I can reveal enemies
also I keep forgot hang out with my clan
mobile clan here oh yeah so this was one
of our biggest gripes or your biggest
gripes playing the beta was that there
was no way to really indicate who your
squad was and like he was telling you
play with your squad and we were like
well how do we know who our squad is
everyone looks the same now they have
these icons and color coordination where
you know the yellow icons if you can see
it right next to his head or helmets
we so close will now tell you that you
know hey that's your squad how to play
be with them cuz you said there's like a
bonus - right no bonus for being with
the squad
yeah it's it's should well you see it
there's nowt to see it was two times
experience I'm getting who they got some
cards robbed oh here we go
did they the guy you killed had two
cards already equipped and I really tell
ya but who knows how long it could just
be mental though right like ah I lost
because cards I think that there's
ultimately still gonna be that like it
comes down to you playing the game and
having skill but totally it depends on
what they cook the cards to do I suppose
I got that deluxe but I can't play says
Dallas Mahalo
I think deluxe only gives you what three
days early access is that what it is
whereas ooh that was hot whereas you
need actually a early access to play the
early access the early access is a five
dollar monthly subscription I believe so
yeah you would need that to play not
just those deluxe pre-order whoo
so there's no way for you to get to
those corridors right you have to go
through the doors what do you mean yeah
it's kind of odd and this is galactic
conquest I think we got a push
Kevin Lauritzen this is the early access
version whoa Ned Flanders I don't know
if they have first-person mode only
servers but you can go first-person if
you want to think it's a choice I think
that one of the reason right Rob if I
remember correctly why he likes
third-person is because he can see more
yeah sorry like I knew it was the reason
why we were like stuck in this room is
because that's what we I think we joined
this game late yeah are you guys want
though what how did you win that oh you
killed them
yeah the droids are trying to get into
them get into the facility just write
jokes on them they they are can we see
some Yoda gameplay yeah we can do some
Yoda later so here are your victory
poses nice yeah they're cool that could
have been you robbed all right let's see
how Oh No go back to personnel real
quick I wanna see how much oh okay not
bad you level of like 2/3 150 is not
much yeah but that's got to be one of
those things where it's uh based off of
I did right so like the better you do
probably the more points you get or
credits maybe all right let's should we
do this oh you're gonna do it all right
here we go put some of those greens on
Oh Oh or that purple that one we got
from the from the pre-order though so
yeah please okay what's this
schwow health regeneration shorter than
normal that's pretty good I like that
thought you couldn't put all the cards
on I don't know how I was able to was
that because my rank was my rank 22 how
are you 22 you okay you were 22 before
you put those on by the way I saw that
green number earlier I did I saw that 22
therefore like I don't as anyone else in
chat play yeah I saw your level 22
though before you equip those cards 100%
I will I can 100% verify that you were
22 and that was with no cards
okay BP monkey said that angry Joe
ranted on the on the post game rewards
that everyone gets the same okay so I
guess that's kind of unfortunate that
you doing better doesn't necessarily
gain you more benefit but well we'll see
that will confirm or deny that here
shortly
I'd say Rob was middle of the pack last
game see how he does this time this time
he has cards on he's got a better
thermal detonator and a really good
thermal dead and then I don't remember
what else you equipped I think was like
lower cooldown and something else
oh yes that was what we get though he
had to jump on you and kill you that guy
only had one card those double check
okay yep yeah so you have the regen life
or regionally okay good you leveled up
by buying loot crate's that's possible
that has it's very possible that has to
be it we definitely didn't equip the
cards that last game and we were 22 so
[Music]
but I mean how much okay so the
difference there is that it's leveling
is like you lever just more cards right
it's not equipped but I thought it was
equipped but it's it's literally just
getting a card will boost your so we
should have looked at what the pre-order
bonus was with just like the oh there's
gradually we can find out afterwards he
was to your right like hiding against a
role rare glue a lot of pre-order people
on guy had a tripmine some Eve Sam B
gave me saying the better cards you own
the higher that your level is okay okay
I apologize for not knowing the system
it's just very different there's stuff
in play that you wouldn't assume yeah
would affect that kind of stuff so we're
all learning together on the stream
thank you guys what is leveling up to
you guys ed Flanders it allows you to
equip more cards star cards so you have
to be at least level 10 to equip three
cards I think it's like is it 5 4 2 it's
like 5 for a second slot and then like
10 for your last slot okay good yeah I
mean that's good at least it's showing
people that uh yeah you don't need them
cards as long as you've got the high
ground as a op1 would say that guy's not
rideable though you do level up by
playing Kevin we just happen to open all
our crates that we had purchased before
so that's why we're higher level if we
had just played to start we would have
been level 1 level 0 or 0 now now level
1 right no it's zero oh really so you
you leveled like almost 1 in 2/3 from
just playing one match because oh that
was your actual personal so there's two
rankings if you guys didn't know that
there's like class rank and then there's
also like your personal rank right
mm-hmm exactly I'm gonna let Rob play
he's in the zone
duplicates give you a credits credits
so far the the cards have not proven to
be that well if what if I played a
little better we could probably see
something I know that wasn't a shout
like a shot at you or a jab it was just
more it's not like significant mass mass
Boyd games how come you guys are able to
play earlier so if you have EA early
access or origin early access you can
access the game now on PC as well as
Xbox one and that costs I believe five
dollars and you get to play for 10 hours
so Rob's probably got roughly eight more
hours
turn this puppy around over on gun G
nope exit G Wow
it takes that long to exit got a hold it
man hey man if you're on a turret it
would take a while for you to get off
the turret
ooh nice you get 108 to them unless I
was just to the ship show what's up Rob
but nice active reload oh you you are
lucky this time you got away oh that
doesn't work sir
okay that works though now I'd love a
hese
b.p monkey singing if EA access came to
ps4 he'd have it yeah its Xbox and ps4
he writes down to five lives you're now
out of lives defeat great can the maps
be played solo against the AI as dark
Darth três três on say that again can
the maps can you play solo against AI
yeah there is an arcade mode but you
don't get rewards right you do get
rewards so there are like again these
milestone challenges and you can get
credits out of them so you take this
type of stuff right here okay so you get
those done that got it alright let's
change up the class so what else we can
do here specialist I like it so let's do
this oh you know what else we can do
oh wait yeah so these are some weapons
we got which I can put mods on a lot of
people are getting me with that gun
Oh what were they yeah well at least
from the time that I looked at the kill
feed so this stuff right here you know
you like a lot of milestone complete
structure so did you have to do like
unlock the other mole right okay so
that's not tied into all right what kind
Specialists cards do you have some
bluesman the marksman is pretty good oh
you're right increased melee damage
I guess this stuff sure and then thing
oh that's good like so the other okay
just so people know like I just read it
there it's like you can like upgrade in
the like in another menu
the thing is Rob can't do some of these
things while he's queueing right right
actually the gang our to craft yeah you
know why its hold on stuck in here all
right there we go uh I won't say though
for what I can tell it's very early it's
only been a few matches mm-hmm but I
don't feel like the card stuff has
really I don't know I have to felt like
it's made a huge difference but we've
only tried so many cards do we have how
much time why because I don't say we can
quit 20 minutes see if we can upgrade
these cards let's say after this match
okay well I have 20 minutes you can keep
going if you want your I think you're
not you're not booked up till 3 I think
yeah so you get solo this why I can't I
can't read chat though at the same time
I guess that's true if someone if
someone wants to come yell in that be
claw I'll see you who's available
yeah battle-field v3t it looks like just
us opening all the crates leveled us up
or leveled up his assault I don't know
you're playing specialist right now
right yeah I think it was the same deal
there cuz I could put yeah so your
specialist is only 21 I think from what
chat was saying okay
oh how did you not get credit oh did you
get credit Oh Rob going for the big
reload
there's so many people in front of you
so this crap
so that infiltration thing I have on I
think it what did it do
prove okay so maybe it's just range it's
like it basically turns my thing into a
I'll let's do this
Oh at least so you didn't buy enough
Starfighter packs cuz you're you're not
level ten on your uh over here yeah I
love flying I just want to play a little
of the saying what a wing here see what
happens you God I got damage and fire
eight so let's see what that does
uh real stormer G I'm not a hundred
percent on the duration of the do you
know the length of the campaign I know
we have Annie's article it's like 10
hours ish okay I would check there's a
GameSpot news article that has the
estimated time but Rob's thinking
okay that guy just fly into a building
this is what Rob loves here though I do
I really do
it's tough
that's another thing I want to mention
because loot crate's is still a thing
that's being discussed in the chat is
that we never got a epoch out of the
loot crate's
so okay
gave up this isn't the right map for it
gotcha so we never got an epoch out of
the loot crate's
so that's good I feel like you got a
craft to increase the rarity of the
cards obviously mm-hmm which we will do
after this match but I was able to put
three cards on on some of the classes
not injured Wow
what yeah he's just got the pre-order
that's good yep and if you see
differences in levels it's because of
the whatever he got from the crates is
do you know if there's any benefit past
ten for the for the like level of your
your class yeah I believe when you hit
past ten then you can start crafting to
the next to the tier of legendary
that guy's just did not care that you're
shooting in Rob's going in guns blazing
Oh oh my god I was worth it so that was
a one of your abilities right that pulse
coming right yeah I think it's scanned
and was able to show me a bunch of dudes
all right so let's see if I can upgrade
these cards because that takes a while
like so again like look ranking up your
player or your rank I start your class
and mine's gone takes takes a while oh
you guys are meaning to get to ten that
that would take a lot of time yeah so as
everyone mentioned you can't get epics
from loot crate's cuz they took it out
as you told me that earlier
oh that's fine I would say the rares
were kind of few and far between though
too when we're opening them it's not
like we were getting a bunch so yeah
okay
that's weird you couldn't you couldn't
upgrade no I think I should be able to
no no you can't
oh my overall rank so that's how it
works
wait none of these are checked off
you're not 25 and your personal ranks
not 20 okay so let's there were slots
only 22 - so you can't equip past ray or
you can't upgrade past rare that's
that's good right I mean that's the only
one like the epics that we've got were
from the pre-order stuff so so 15 to go
to rare right and that's personal level
so my personal level is what again like
two or three I can't find it where is it
there either so you're only two so you
got a lot of long ways to go but I guess
doing challenges and stuff will help
right or is that just for the rewards
sometimes you're I would think you get
crafting parts I don't know if it will
experience I doubt it okay so you still
have to rank up
so there are there are there are
definitely things that are stopping you
from like just outright paying to win
though yeah I hate using my words gonna
get blown up in the chat probably put
all these juices de games 89 saying
infiltration cards mark enemies and
equips the EE for weapon
[Music]
uh jokey my I believe it's also on Xbox
as well as PC we're currently paying on
PC though you can get credits through
milestones Martin so if you play the
single-player and do certain things or
play multiplayer and do certain things
you will get credits that way the other
type of currency flaming wings that we
had earlier which were crystals is the
stuff you pay for the credit is stuff
you get in the game right yeah and out
of rewards as well so that someone says
the challenges are they stupid
well they they're they're fairly bland I
mean they're nothing like that crazy
they can be like specific to a weapon
like epic he filled his weapon or play X
amount of time in a match or a conquest
or something the regular day saying that
the robbed cat is pretty curious cute my
shirt is cute no he's saying you're cute
oho oh that's gave Jewett for anyone
that doesn't know the sound though is on
point
bakka no guy Jim so he's some type of
yes we will keep those credits after
launch your your bows anything that
happens here in the ten hours right will
carry over yeah otherwise we we look
like like a fool for spending the money
oh I would not recommend that nor in
general applying but yeah ah come here
that Oh
he's try to slow-mo Anya put the brakes
on
I love a good dogfight says Bill Elliott
yeah this one's uh this one's good
bargain at 14-14 asking why Jeff was
fired I'm guessing you're talking about
Kurtzman and that was a long time ago
he's actually back in the office as
part-time mom and that was a trap
question that I'm not answering Oh what
is that
that is awesome all that missile just
ripped I have a free-fire posted a lock
on ya the gameplay and all that is cool
I think that there's just a sour taste
in a lot of people's mouths because of a
loot crate stuff but I obviously think
from granted it's been limited
experience not playing but watching Rob
after like you know using the crates no
no I don't feel like there's been too
much like lost from like if you didn't
do it you know some stuff is sped up
obviously but I think you'd be fine like
there are a lot of people claims just
now that didn't have very much other
than the pre-order stuff I don't know I
think just trying to get past that and
if you love Star Wars obviously you know
everyone that I've talked to that's at
least played the multiplayer has a set
that's playing the game is locked
get off us
god the starfighters stuff is so good
Lobo Louie we're playing on PC oh that
was nice this is now on that home air
yeah
Taz cat I rob prefers controller for the
for the Starfighter stuff oh yeah for
sure absolutely
he said that much improved right one
percent yeah it's also because in in a
perfect world actually you would love to
play on a choice of a joystick yeah
that's as you had mentioned earlier it's
one of those things that kind of comes a
little bit later joystick support
probably because it's a little niche oh
yeah I know one for PC really there's
not much there's not much support for a
console ps4 has something go
what controllers good now right you're
liking it oh yeah absolutely
oh it's the rolling right right right
now this is like an actual dogfight in
the last game it's like I do a I do a
flip and I'm upside down I can't roll
out of it so it's like I'm stuck upside
down trying to lock on your good run
though can you know I got away someone's
in the sleeve oh you could be Kyler
though hold on let me equip my cards now
we got that purple from the pre-order
right so you know that epic everything
else is up he's pretty calm down he's
top speed cool down total health sure
all right
by the time you quit God just man I'm
not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
because because I know I didn't have any
cards are we gonna finally get to see
this ship more in action
the last Jedi oh for sure didn't you saw
a trailer yeah we better do some work
where are they at well they're trying to
do the bombing yeah that's what boys me
his voice yeah isn't it ridiculous some
of these voices are pretty bad I know
[Laughter]
you're making oh I know that's exactly
like pilots say he wouldn't say is
getting shot you're making me angry no
way I will say his ship is pretty bad
out it is pretty sick tie silencer
oh my god I can't take much more of your
boys oh is this PO oh you got a win Rob
for the Empire first order first order
oh did he shake you distressing that's
Sean Connery well your mother said
Trebek post shook yeah that's why he's
the ace pilot after all
I see the thing
after adjustment sensitivity there's an
excuse
it's pilot versus pilot right now Rob we
almost nailed that he's playing games
with you
damn uneventful that's alright
much time we have time it would be a
good person ask Jake named Marty I am
like because you got you guys definitely
have to stop at three so I wish I wasn't
joining matches male just hang in here
joining matches and uh halfway three
matches
[Music]
anvil won't gain anything I don't like
that the matches just end all of a
sudden like that I wouldn't be as bad if
we were we're in the whole match that
was like happy
okay so Martin said that we've got 60
more credits that time I wasn't wrong I
think you're saying postgame we got six
more credits
well that's quick it's okay he was
looking at chat all right Mike said he
come and really perfect time in nature
so you guys we've got Mike in here in a
little bit chat with you guys sorry that
I can't say but I was here for the most
important part which is a good case
Oh
damn man this guy's on you he's gotten
me twice oh yeah yeah process now you
got him earlier yeah when you guys were
when you were part of the first order I
was that was that that guy was PO no I
wasn't PO
all right that's it
you put anything on your you win yeah
two cards over then follow them ready go
I like that it has the little revenge
meter under it yeah there's also there's
also avenged good luck have fun thank
you thanks Eric see Eric
what's up Mike hi how did uh open crates
go with a huh $90 hundred yeah about $90
but someone who does not have the EI
origin access it would get a 90 he you
know wasn't sorry explain that to me you
have to pay a lot oh yeah cuz you pay
$10 a month for xanax or something
that's five dollars yeah it what it was
I was actually expecting it to be worse
it wasn't as bad as I thought in that of
the tears Legendary's the one that you
have to upgrade right the crappy parts
as we've discussed those do not show up
and crates and apparently we know we
open I think more than 60 not not one
epic one tear down so it was just rare
and only a few I want to see like four
to five rare carbs in that Mass unboxing
all right crash it's got boot I see Eric
green the YouTube friend of the site
saying do you want to know the
statistics yeah like did you record them
Eric green if he has the status
incidentally in terms of what so overall
was is it Mari more worried about the
progression or less a producer so what
it did do so stark arts the the more and
the better the sour cards you have
affects your class rank so I went from 0
to 22 so for assault I am now able to
have three slots which I think actually
I'll go back out which that's your
actual level I thought yeah there's two
so and this is my overall level others
level and rank yeah where is that
goddamn thing the menus is so weird
Eric green says you got three hours out
of all those okay 13 out of accident
that's hurting more than I thought too
so the thing is is now and this is where
at least I am I'm happy that this this
overall rank is what's stopping me from
upgrading so for instance these guys
right so this is a legendary card
my back I'm gonna write down these stats
actually just so you said average number
of cards per container was four point
four one seven average number of parts
was that weapon parts was fifty one for
crafting parts okay fifty one point
three six thank you Eric green you're
doing God's work so if you see here I
have to be overall rank of fifteen in
order to upgrade this to a pick meaning
my overall rank is what is what's tied
to like actual in-game progression so
you cannot start this game with a blank
slate and buy your way to all legendary
cards that's not the case you have to
have you have to actually level up in
the game to get to 15 so that's better
than what it's been it's better however
that's really the only thing holding me
back because I also have a shitload of
crafting parts and I have a shitload of
credits now just from all open always
use until you get to the right level
right and so regardless leveling up a
class I hope will take time naturally or
in-game percent chance of an uncommon is
fifty two point seven okay and the
amount of cart and the other thing
that's different is so there are the the
pre-order stuff I got those actually had
ethics a lot of them did and those were
specific to Ray kylo Ren and those were
the only ones that had to to or down
downwards to two items in a crate okay
meaning that the the core crates that
you open the trooper the star fighter in
the hero the core crates of the game you
will always from what we open do you you
will always get four to five cart cards
you will never get below that okay so
like the daily crate or like an
objective crate or like a challenge
crate I think those will warrant like
fewer cards and but maybe maybe better
maybe the chance of getting like an epic
or like a
even the even legendary will be higher
okay interesting
we're not legendary epic epic is the
second legend Ares the best so confused
about all of it oh dude it's so
confusing but I also got a bunch of
weapons too with mods is this not quite
sure let's check it out
Scott that was a good rap match so it's
the star foot the dog fighting a
separate chrome of the ground combat
thing it's not like battlefield where
you can be no it's there's so certain
maps will have vehicles okay
galactic conquest is sorry galactic
assault is your your basically your your
main mode with yeah it's the most
biofuel desk there are stages to it so
like it's member hall from the last game
we're just like walkers go here now it's
indoors now it's the Jenner in the end
it's a lot of that for the galactic
assault okay and then some maps will
have ships I feel like there are a few
galactic assault maps that are just
infantry based
so again I say yeah I guess that's what
it is I probably took creative Liberty
with a lot well they definitely did with
a lot of these weapons um you'd be
surprised
they're like there are some first-order
weapons and stuff from the Latin from
the last movie scrubbing the movie to
see what they can use in the background
stuff yeah I always loved how like Star
Wars just start off with like we have no
money so that air filter just slap that
on this mp40 like this is the designs
this looks so funny when you really
think about it cool that's that's
feature Sega's [ __ ] that's good
that's work to prove its going to be
good I love it I do you have time for
another match before we end yeah yeah I
think we have one more match so should
be good here
yeah use Kazuma Kiryu and YouTube chat
we're saying man I miss collective
galactic conquest so much I was just
thinking that when you said that to from
battle yeah that's like exactly that
that's what that's why I keep or wanting
to say oh man see that what class have
you been playing mostly assault and
specialists those my fav I'll stick to
that are you playing mainly in third
person yeah that's kind of the would
play situational awareness and the ads
peek around this is you haven't I have
not played this this looks pretty cool
this was in the earlier games too but it
was obviously not yeah
come on dude a hippo well I knew it
hippo elk was not doing anything well I
knew it wasn't gonna be affected
whatsoever what the hell are you Jesus
the Evans got some weird wildlife I did
not know that hold man I thought that
was to be hit solid off-map drop let's
do this dims nice a little submachine
gun here I'll do this reveal
this might get on you when you roll yeah
it's on your boots boots stepped in
hippo duty mm-hmm man this map looks
pretty good
rebel base for a while right yeah I mean
this I'm sure this was an actual battle
right actually I don't know if if then
they had a fleet yeah and obviously
after the first Star Wars I wonder if
this is supposed to reflect that
there we go
whoa
you know I'm still not doing as
following my teammates only have none
this is the 1i that submachine gun look
yeah it's it's precision he doesn't have
much range that's for sure what are you
doing dude so here's an example of a
plastic assault map no Sh
vehicles yeah so sorry
galactic assault is what it's like the
main mode rolling points serious
guns got a crazy rate of fire yeah it
does
/ yes and the salt also has a standard
shotgun no I want to get closer
obviously it's like pop G into the ball
damn they had some range damn I should
has gone for it mace Windus dick oh oh
dude to death oh my god
death troopers so these are cards are
here
yeah I'm just putting these on I got all
of them dude these are you're equipping
these are these one-time use no no no
they're not burn cards oh my god I'm
just I'm just yeah right now I just have
insane amount of health so I have more
damn and always forget what I put on
more health and I think every killer or
a headshot I get I get health regardless
these guys are really powerful that's
that's specific to them that vampire
ability yeah well you I've seen the card
in many other classes and instances but
you have it for this classroom that card
is just specific to this class yeah what
else what other specific thing is that
this class hat um I don't think they
have much damage stuff but
like why would you do this class oh well
this is a class that I can't this isn't
a default class this is because I played
well great
oh it's like a hero class right it's
like the in-between over here oh okay
see throughout three thousand eight
thousand subscribers points you're
getting each game yeah okay officers
have like proximity buffs I'm assuming
yeah and you know it's what was my in my
experience playing at this event and
everything man it's like you get it if
you get to like at it like a tank on
Kashyyyk the AAT tank droid tank I like
did really well sit and then I was able
because I'd sold me bow points I was
able to pick ray and not ray it would
have been like I was able to pick kylo
Ren I was able to like pick it like
Darth Maul like all within the same
match like back to back because I had
raked up so many kills which is I don't
know like you can snowball with battle
points if you do really well yeah yeah
the vegetation man have you felt that
so this is the specialist it's kind of
got like a longer range sniper rifle but
my secondary is like a burst fire
it's called infant infiltration and it
Wow and it also I believe it reveals
enemies on the mat oh wait I didn't do
this dude yeah I'm gonna wait boyfriend
a TST the Chickenwing so overall does
this is this more fun than the first
game like the first game I played four
maybe six hours and look okay this is
just we're pretty repetitive but this
has a lot of variation yeah I I really
do think it's it's it's just it's I
think it feels better I think I think
there's just there's just warrants more
like team play and like again with
squads and luckily from the beta they've
made the improvement I can see when my
squad is but all the weapons feel so
much better
have you started campaign at all yeah we
played the first mission on the stream
yeah well actually was the prologue it
was quick it was pretty quick and the
regular difficulty was really easy
something else in the chat mention I
agree
so I would recommend turning that up oh
wow turning what up the game the
difficulty oh sorry I was the rebel base
where yeah it's in that 200 your boy
laughs my laughs sighs oh wow there are
a lot of guys out here out [ __ ] those
death animations like there's a lot of
impact on those blasters as opposed to
last time mm-hmm sure no go for the
elite character elite characters oh you
meet the heroes yeah she's probably
gonna see if I can ornate ESD
yeah I said wait
also in the meantime you see a being
knocked out here to blow it up a
tribunal
Anslinger you should activate something
yeah that was enacted real oh okay never
I'll like hit it and then I never get a
chance to uh I should do this huh damn
that is for right now no oh my god
oh that run that's Kyle oh it's on here
too I really have to hold this taking
one for the team I guess that's really
slow protect me yeah
I think the only one person can be like
actually engage you're holding oh I'm
pretty sure I have to hold it main gate
open
just waiting are they I can wait a
little longer I don't think I can be an
ATSC anywhere couple of sip wait was
that Kyle Kyle oh and mall you know okay
I was gonna say cuz why is Kyle here if
you're not the first order but they
wouldn't I guess it just mixes the magic
yeah how's that small
yeah it doesn't sound like something
pylos a Shane Collins on YouTube we are
playing on PC right now I don't know
what the specs are oh man oh I don't
know
Ultra settings with Max but I do not
know what
so far this map seems good in terms of
varying from outdoor environments to
closed borders inside yeah they kind of
all end in like a yeah they all kind of
end in a yeah I believe it's a tense
Eddy 70 oh okay yeah they all end just
kind of a close-quarters situation I
feel like and often times it's where
like most matches end like sometimes
I'll be like oh we got this in the bag
as far as like the advancing team and it
just ends in like a corridor firefight
there's a last stand
yeah and and like more awesome and I
feel like they can get out of it oh that
was a really good grenade or a thermal
detonator I think that's like it was an
epic or legendary that I got the one you
just threw yeah a bit more damage
I would imagine everything radius as
well what's the maximum players in a
match 40 that's a good question more
let's get fashion I want to stay for
that land oh yeah battlefront to max
players
according to this forum why are we only
getting 40 players Max and multiplayer
yeah right now I think I have a
machine-gun
yeah it looks like Oh remember that gun
for the first game it's got that Jerome
on top I think yeah wait we go
what's his name oh oh man oh wait bingo
was his name-o ô was his name-o I
thought you might like you forgot kylo
Ren here's a lightsaber so cool I love
that I love it too great see I should
have done that someone just picked him
yeah because I was trying for my damn
cards on all you got boss gasps is that
boss above way over the to that you
don't have unlocked right here do you
know yeah Vader and the Emperor blank
spaces
oh I'm expecting or it's just empty
slots actually cuz cuz different these
are the ones I can play on this map but
it'll it'll change I believe do you
unlock I didn't through cards or beating
campaign or something it's I believe
it's just progression based stuff within
oh four item maybe it is campaign there
it's it's like challenges for the most
part okay oh man what a bus well I'm not
gonna put any cards on oh cool cool damn
you guys play for a while two hours yes
while you're not here it's two it's on
here pretty well right I don't know
actually
why does that guy have that guy has
everything you see that he had all four
acolytes assist kills with kill streak
and epi that happens a lot really yeah
they need to vary it depends if he like
if someone stomps that's what happens
well that's gonna do it we don't have
time apologies but cool thank you guys
so much for tuning in and I hope that
unboxings section unboxing lootcrate
section wasn't too frustrating you can
go play this right now that's right um
you see an Xbox not yet PlayStation I
believe it's the the EA access or Origin
access is not available for PlayStation
I believe it's the Xbox and PC okay and
then this will be out November 17th
a week from Friday right and or if you
pre-ordered that's three days earlier so
there are a lot of opportunities I guess
to play this game first three sessions
as well right through first three
missions for yeah campaign with the EA
access okay yeah we got if you missed
the lobby today at five no sorry
actually in like 10 minutes we're
putting up a breakout video our
discussion about the multiplayer
progression if you want more in-depth
stuff on that yeah I don't know when our
review will be up Alessandro spent a
couple days down in Redwood Shores to
check it out sometime next week
yeah but he'll live multiplayer
progression in multiplayer impressions
sorry going up today oh he's gonna do
that later today or tomorrow cool yeah
well yeah again thank you guys so much
and we'll see you next time we got
plenty of streams tomorrow I believe is
a neat one enough we talked about it we
talked about no it's differently I can't
say
but stay tuned every morning stream at
11:00 and then you're damn sure we're
gonna do some more valve and stuff next
week sure
cool cool thanks Rob thank you guys take
care yeah